l'intérêt de la france et des français
ç'aurait été que emmanuel macron ne
prennent pas cette présidence de l'union
européenne en pleine présidence en
pleine campagne présidentielle
l'intérêt de la france et des français
si ça avait été son objectif aurait été
que cette présidence de l'union
européenne qui n'arrive qu'une fois tous
les quatorze ans eh bien elle soit elle
soit repoussée de quelques mois qu'elle
soit repoussée après l'élection
présidentielle pour donner de la force
au nouveau président élu qui aurait pu
du coup impulser une nouvelle politique
emmanuel macron a choisi de fragiliser
l'intérêt de la france et des français
en prenant cette présidence de l'union
européenne alors même qu'il va y avoir
une campagne présidentielle et que tous
les ministres qui vont siéger dans les
conseils dans les conseils des ministres
européens leurs collègues vont se
demander si en mai ils seront toujours
là donc c'est une source de fragilité
c'est dommage maintenant l'important
c'est quelle stratégie on propose pour
l'europe non à l'europe de la naïveté
oui à l'europe puissance c'est mon
programme